this past week it's been revealed that
t1 ceo joe marsh and several other t1
employees were part of a private t1 fan
discord server many t1 fans have been
outraged to find out that not only were
marsh and other t1 employees sharing
exclusive and behind the scenes content
there for free but that he also made
personal and crew jokes about one of the
team's players there there's even been
an accusation that he failed to act on a
racist remark left in the server by one
of the users it's an incredibly strange
story all round let's get into it
okay we're going to be doing a deep dive
today into a secret discord so while
you're buckling up for that just make
sure you're subscribed to the channel
and if you enjoyed the video at the end
make sure you leave a like on your way
out the door we really do appreciate it
okay so we all know t1 the most
successful org in league's history the
home of faker and probably the team i've
talked about most on this channel other
than tsm in march of this year t1
launched their global fan platform
powered by b stage the idea was that
this platform would give t1 fans a more
intimate way to engage with the players
especially after two years of a pandemic
that meant they couldn't really see them
in person the platform offers fans
exclusive content including behind the
scenes videos and even the chance to
directly communicate with the players at
the time invent global quoted t1 ceo joe
marsh as saying quote the competitive
edge and legacy of t1 is all thanks to
the support and love from fans i am very
excited that the new platform and
membership will allow for the players
and fans to feel a bit closer now for
the sake of this story it's important to
remember here that this is all a paid
subscription t1 are offering behind the
scenes content but only if you fork out
the cash for it and as far as i'm aware
this system seemed to work well on the
surface until last weekend when all hell
broke loose the korean outlet never
reported that t1 ceo joe marsh have been
sharing daily behind the scenes pictures
of the players to a private discord
called t1 happy house for overseas fans
reportedly the fans who were paying 70
000 won or roughly 53 us dollars for
their t1 memberships for all that
exclusive behind the scenes content were
not happy about this it sounded a lot
like what they were paying for was being
given to others mainly western fans for
absolutely free on top of that the
article also outlined an alleged case of
racism in the discord server as well
some of you may remember the recent t1
protest trucks that angry fans have been
sending to t1 games in protest of their
management well allegedly one user
reacted to that in the discord server by
suggesting that quote we will put kimchi
in the truck invin global's ashley kang
outlined the controversy further on
twitter she shared images allegedly from
the discord which appeared to show merch
leaks from ceo joe marsh as well as
details of contract negotiations with
players agents and behind the scenes
pictures of the players there was also a
conversation which allegedly showed joe
marsh discussing a player photo shoot
with fans in which he asked who was
going to spray oil on their jungler
owner which he later described as a
thirst trap so this was pretty crazy
news not only did it look like t1
membership subscribers were missing out
on exclusive content being given to
others for completely free but the
discord server in which that content was
being shared in was being accused of
containing at least one racist comment
from a user and a conversation in which
t1 ceo joked about covering a player in
oil as a thirst trap kang also shared a
message allegedly sent to t1 membership
subscribers by t1 in which they
apologize for the situation specifically
they mentioned the sharing of photos and
information on an unofficial discord
channel and the fact that the discord
communications were conducted in only
one language they resolved to not make
the same mistake in future said that all
t1 members had now left the discord and
pledged that those with t1 membership
will receive more and better exclusive
content moving forward this message was
not a public statement from t1 and
pressure began to mount earlier this
week for there to be a more official
addressing of the situation on monday
joe marsh did just that he shared a twit
longer in which he began by apologizing
from the bottom of his heart for what he
called a confusing and disappointing
turn of events he admitted that he and
several other t1 employees were involved
in the discord server and asked for
forgiveness he explained how he and
other t1 employees disclosed sensitive
information and posted pictures that
originated internally marsh claimed he
thought these pictures would be okay for
him to post because they were not going
to be used anywhere else but admitted
this was wrong and that it undermined
the trust of the t1 fan membership he
also acknowledged that he made
inappropriate jokes about owner on the
discord server including the joke about
covering him with oil as a thirst trap
marsh added that he has apologized to
owner directly for this and that he will
make sure nothing like this ever happens
again now at this point on the twit
longer we reached something that wasn't
touched on at all in the t1 membership
message shared by ashley kang on twitter
the allegations of racist remarks on the
discord server marsh said he had been
made aware of racist remarks in the
server and admitted that neither he nor
other t1 employees filed a complaint or
took action he stressed that if he had
known about it at the time then he would
have done something but acknowledged
that wasn't an excuse that he should
have been more mindful given a similar
past incident and that it was a clear
mistake to not realize what was going on
finally marsh admitted that it was wrong
for him to remain on the server as for
the future he announced his decision to
take a six-month salary cut to never
talk about the team's personal details
on any channels and that t1 employees
who are on the server will be sent to a
disciplinary committee many of the top
replies in korean to marsha's tweet were
less than positive some describe trust
as being shattered said they were
disappointed and urged the ceo to
disclose the relevant staff involved in
the discord server but it's unclear
whether we'll hear any more on this
matter marsha's statement seem pretty
final and i'm sure that both he and t1
will not want to draw any more attention
at this time for those of you that have
been following t1 haven't been going
through the easiest of times this year
on the rift their record-breaking
perfect regular season in spring and
their second place finish at msi would
be enviable to any other team but
outside of the game there's been a lot
of friction between them and some
elements of their fanbase in july we
spoke about how faker is suing his toxic
fans who have sent him images and videos
described by his legal team as
unspeakably foul and just last week we
saw the return of the protest trucks
being sent to t1 games with messages
calling out t1 for what some fans see as
bad management from the team's coaches
and this all comes at a time when joe
marsh has recently spoken about t1 fans
getting way too close to players in
public even to the point of stalking
protesting in korea is a way of life and
part of the culture i don't mind the
protests what i mind is fans lingering
in the alley and popping out at my guys
when they're walking home and like
trying to get pictures with them or
lingering outside our building like
that's not cool like the trucks whatever
they are what they are like i'd rather
have trucks than no fans but
the stalking my players and like ruining
their lives and having them be afraid to
go to the movies because they're worried
that they don't practice too much
because they've had 18 hours of scrims
and like they can't have a social life
like that's draining on my guys more
than like a couple trucks the last thing
joe marsh mentioned in his twitter
longer about the discord server was that
he especially wanted to apologize to t1
players and staff as they prepare for
summer playoffs and a potential world's
run this year and we're not even done
with it yet has seen more headlines for
t1 than some other teams see in years
both good and bad they have an extremely
talented team of four up-and-comers
assisted by the veteran of veterans
himself in faker they have a good shot
of returning to the top in a way we've
not seen from this team in years but to
truly realize that potential i'm sure
that everyone at t1 will want to keep
any friction with fans and controversies
like this weeks to an absolute minimum
[Music]
you